practice makes perfect so what's up guys
jason is a little bit late today for
filming for my video day so I thought
you know what I'm going to get my camera
and just do a quick little impromptu
sitting on the floor at TDs and talk to
you about what's going on with the book
and also share the left hand about
practice making things perfect I'm a big
believer that the quantity leads to the
quality that you have to get good at
what you're doing and the only way that
it comes yes you can model success yes
you can get the gear yes you can you
know read books and watch videos but you
have to do the work to you got to
actually take some action it reminds the
people who want to go snowboarding you
know they buy the board and they buy the
gear and the face mask and the goggles
and the star and do all the research on
amazon for what the right socks aren't
aware and compare their socks so
somebody else's socks you know the right
boots and then they watch all the videos
about how to snowboard and do tricks and
you know the right way to go down and
you know read some books and you know do
all the work and all the research and
they have all the knowledge but you
haven't gotten down the hill right like
you got to get on the hill and do it too
and doesn't mean you go out on the hill
and you're naked and you just fall down
and you know there's no planning but you
gotta you gotta actually take some
action of what you're doing to all the
planet in the world won't save you if
you don't do anything about it and so
whatever it is that you want to get
better at if it's speaking if it's
youtube if it's selling if it's creating
the you know but better product if it's
dancing whatever it is you need to
practice you need to practice you need
to have structured practice you need to
practice the right things but you still
you need to practice and do it and so
how I applying this to my book is I'm
going to be doing a bunch of interviews
for the book and I had my first one with
with the guy named Jay who's been on my
channel you may have seen him in the end
suppress Oh videos he's gonna pop by
later on today and film with me and he
he was my first one and I've got a bunch
of interviews before but this the first
one on my book and i'm scheduled in a
bunch in advance hopefully before the
book comes out because i want to
practice too so before i do a big
interview i want to have done a couple
and my belt already and the first thing
i did once I finished doing the
interview was I sent it off to some
advisors that I have a sentence my
publisher sent it to my agents i sent it
to advisors who helping me with the book
and I said hey guys watch this interview
it starts at whatever the mark was 13
minutes or whatever is the first part
was just chit-chatting let me know what
you think like let me know how I can get
better did you like it was it valuable
you know great I'm sure there's a lot of
pros but what do I need to improve on to
get better one of the comments that came
back was they loved how I flipped the
script on them and how I asked the host
what his one word was kind of walking
through the exercise and also be careful
that I don't tell the same stories each
time so when I'm doing different
interviews I don't I don't see the same
examples each time because some people
have overlapping audience and they want
to hear the same thing each time so some
good like helpful messages actually know
what like you know what let's link it up
here too I would love your feedback let
me know what you thought of my interview
and it's great to hear the praise but
what could I do better what do you think
I should do better as a consumer as
someone who's you know maybe buying the
book what what could I do better in that
kind of interview because it's going out
to somebody else's audience too and I
want to be able to make an impact and
not just sell the book but but make an
impact like touch somebody make them
think whether they buy the book or not
just touch them a little bit let me know
what you think of that video really
really really mean a lot and whatever it
is that you want to get better at don't
just wing it don't just show up and
expect to be great and then get
depressed when you're not great and
don't get so sad when you're not great
at the start like expect the sock expect
your first video to be terrible don't
compare your first video to somebody
else's 100th video right you don't know
how to make that quality yet you have
the taste you know what's good and
you're frustrated that you can't make
that I know what good food tastes like
but I can't
make that food and if I try to make that
Spanish omelet I'm probably gonna suck
the first time out and that's okay but
if I make a thousand of them I'm gonna
get pretty darn good at it practice guys
get on the hill get down the hill don't
just buy the gear do the work let me get
to your feedback from last week first up
in a while Evan I bought your book much
love and the well I don't remember
seeing that receipt guys make sure like
we can't really keep track the
publishers do such a bad job of keeping
track of data that I need to know why
not how many we've sold but also to send
you the bonuses so please email in your
receipt I think it's one more day
Diamond Carmical calm but it's on the
website to emailing your receipt so we
can keep track and give you the bonuses
and the shadows and all that stuff too
but thank you know Li really really
appreciate that Jack clean I'll be
thinking and praying I live in a
southern part of the US where you farm
if you're lucky work a convenience place
thank you for being you and your videos
and J reyez followed up with you can
always share this video or the book page
if your reach using one journalist way
out there or something your share may
make a huge difference I love that I get
the not avisan everybody's at sailing
the position to buy the book or buy
multiple copies of the book but even
sharing sharing your thoughts sharing it
with your friends sharing the link you
know make means means a lot to me if
I've had an impact on your life that
that giving back really means a lot to
me so I thank you for that jackeline and
thank you j your eyes for the suggestion
and stepping up to David hi I mean I
have a reasonably sized email list of
people who downloaded my book so we are
talking mostly entrepreneurs and
achievers would love to interview you
also got a big linkedin following the
send out to looking forward buddy I've
have a lot of respect for you and your
work David I love that let's let's do it
let's connect we can even do it as an
interview on my channel if you want to
have some extra promotional juice and
I'd love to have my audience learn about
YouTube you think that's a fit so I
really appreciate that and let's set it
up I get to practice my interview skills
and storytelling again I love it random
order done I'll be buying it looking
forward to it really appreciate that
links that means a lot to me
I've been thinking for months how I
might be able to help spread the message
of your book I'm planning on making a
video when i get the book and read it I
have a few ideas on this so maybe more
than one video like that I don't have an
email list oh I know I'm supposed to be
gathered email addresses and I haven't
come up with everyone that really
excites me that I know who could be a
good interview for you but I'm still
thinking any help I sincerely appreciate
it guys like it means a lot to me if
you're a youtuber you want to make your
video that's awesome you want to do an
interview together let me know it to
practice my skills there too you know
you don't have to know anybody if you
know somebody again just really means a
lot i'm humbled by all your show of
appreciation and wanted to help
Carmencita i believe that he should get
hooked up with gary vee and where can I
get a copy so Gary's went on the channel
we've done an interview with him we've
done some collaborations so I'll be
reaching out to him see what's going on
and you can get a copy by will lick it
up in the description I think it's in
all of the video descriptions now that
you can find it Evan Carmichael calm /
one word you can pick it up Dwight this
book is on my list and I will get it
next week looking forward to it hashtag
believe i love that Dwight again guys
emailing the receipt when you get it so
we can keep track attain to the bonuses
Nicola we'd love to help but
unfortunately don't have what you're
looking for but I will definitely be
looking to buy the book have you
considered making a promo video for your
book apologies if you already have and I
haven't seen it but I definitely think a
video clearly outlined what we will find
inside I think this video will
definitely boost awareness and sales
Nico thank you for that Nico again I
appreciate anybody who's buying a book
make sure the email that receipt in I
know I'm pounding at home but a lot of
you aren't sending it in so we can't
keep track and send you the bonuses the
crazy bonuses we do have a video we've
have a couple videos if you actually go
to the one word landing page at the top
now I added the this for videos as well
as some excerpts oh those pictures to be
talking about it this excerpts by read
from the book it's a kind of
motivational video style so you can
check those out and hopefully that will
help you if they don't let me know to
you look at those and you know what
that's not what I was looking for I
meant something else let me know and we
could try to get that done
hello Chris at first I didn't know what
your book was about now I'm not too
interested in it pretty sure i'll put in
order once it comes out love that chris
is a ditto from eileen this really made
me want a copy of the book and i only
played it curious about the help request
I do love Evans tens but I have no idea
how the book and now I love the whole
concept though I usually have too much
to say it's hard to see me stopping on
one word maybe two words hyphenated the
book will help you super important to
get it down people won't remember and
you won't remember anyway well we'll
talk maybe i'll make a video just on
that more than one word but yeah i'm
glad that me talking about it has helped
you guys with decision making again let
me know what you think about the book
videos that are on the landing page if
that kind of satisfy the curiosity if
you need more James definitely gonna buy
the book thank you James much love I
thought the book launched already David
not yet december six is when it comes
out sherry would have given up in my
business a long time ago if it wasn't
for you your words all your followers
it's amazing it's been a slow journey
but i feel it's time to blast is
business in the superdrive I love that
sherry I plan on purchasing your book
search your maybe postpone just for the
moment give yourself a pat on the back
the rest will fall into place yeah thank
you I mean I appreciate the love
hopefully the surgeries went okay for
you and decided to see your growth I
love the love that you put in every word
there it means a lot next up hola I have
a hundred thousand and growing reach
let's connect for an interview love your
channel let's do it man you know again
happy to have it on my channel if you
want for extra exposure for you too but
I'd love the opportunity let's connect
shoot me a message and let's put it up
Vivian boy I will talk a lot about your
book on social media I just have a small
youtube channel for the moment I will
also talk about on a video I love it man
feeling the love if you guys need like
social media post to or content that you
think might be a fit let me know and we
can always try to put something together
for you too if you can do the work to
help promote it man I'm happy to put
some art work together for you guys too
hi Evan this is elia fan from Bolivia I
would really love to get the book but I
don't know
how here in Latin America please help me
with this blessings I amazon I'm
assuming Amazon's in Latin America
wherever you are if it's not an Amazon
then let me know if you can't find it
any any of you guys you can't find in
your local amazon for pre-order let me
know and we've been opening up other
markets I'd really have to just tell the
publisher guys let's get it into this
country because we have requests and so
sending me the request really helps d
Goins Evan my friend I reach out to some
people I know and I also live in Las
Vegas maybe there's something I can do
out here to help you promote your book
be in Vegas as visitors around the world
I also have another brand iCard in the
transportation industry which can be
cross promoted possibly we'll see what
we can come up with let me know let me
know let me know man let me know I'm
open I'm game you know this is the
chance to take advantage otherwise you
know usually with this kind of stuff
it's I'm so just focused on doing the
work and making the videos and beaten on
what I'm doing back to topic at the top
right the practicing the hustling the
crafting that I don't really do a lot of
the stuff but I'm vulnerable and open
right now so this this is the time to
take advantage Zeno up and wanting to
spread the message about your book to a
video i have a small channel but every
little bit helps right I just need to
figure out what would work definitely
going to do something though really
appreciate that say no I know you're
hardcore fan I love that thank you for
the love je je Chen got your back
appreciate that can i buy them
bookstores in Thailand I don't have a
credit card in southern book stores
anywhere yet basically the whole point
of pre-orders why people in creator
campaign is that it will be available in
that country so if we get a lot of pre
orders from Thailand then the book
stores will carry in Thailand if nobody
pre-orders in Thailand the book stores
won't carry it there and only be in even
in north america in certain cities right
if like we get lots of pre-orders from
New York all the New York books are
gonna want to buy it if we get no you
know p orders from New York then your
books ours won't want to get so that's
why people do so much through pre-orders
because it's a signal to the bookstores
pick up copies to Eric well 11 hashtag
believe nation called the arms time
let's get this thing going together we
cannot fail I love
Eric thanks man bifocal tastic cut 2015
just period the book much love looking
forward to read it when it arrives again
email in the receipt valishia I will
support your book thanks Evan much love
I love that Felicia well now I've
discovered my one word I love it what is
it that mal let us know and let me know
what what I can do you let me know man
you tell me where you can do whatever
you whatever you're feeling I'm game
let's give it a shot let's build the
sink for the moon gonna end there guys
thank you so much for the love Jason's
here we're gonna we're going to set up
our videos top tens and suppress those
all that awesome awesomeness for the
week let me know what you think about
the topic at the top about practicing
about getting better about not being so
hard on yourself and you're not getting
instant results but also making sure
that you're doing the work consistently
to get better leave in the comments
below if the question about that i'll
answer next week if you have a question
about my book the book writing process
ideas for support whatever else is comes
to mind relating to the book leave in
the comments i will answer you guys next
week thank you so much for watching you
to believe or whatever your one word is
and i'll see you soon